اول صوره للاطفال الناجين بعد انقاذهم من
الضياع اربعين يوما في الغابه الموحشه
اعطي الاطفال دفترا والوانا فرسموا ويلسون
كلب بوليسي قال الاطفال انه رافقهم في
الغابه لايام قبل ان يختفي عن الانظار
وسائل الاعلام وصفحات التواصل في كولومبيا
تتحدث اليوم عن بطوله الكلب ويلسون
[موسيقى]
فقدت اثار الكلب المدرب في بدايه ايام
البحث ويبدو انه عثر على الاطفال اولا
حرسهم لايام ثم ذهب لطلب النجده لكنه ضاع
في الغابه
في البدايه كان الكلب معهم مشوا وعدا
الكلب اليهم وهكذا ولكن في وقت لاحق اختفى
الكلب سالتهم ماذا فعلوا عندما هطل المطر
فقالوا انهم اخذوا اغصانا واوراقا كبيره
واحتموا تحتها
بطله اخرى فقدت حياتها في سبيل نجاه
الاطفال امهم مجدلين تبين انها كانت على
قيد الحياه لمده اربعه ايام قبل ان تلفظ
انفاسها الاخيره وهي من زود الاطفال بدقيق
الكاسفه لياكلوه ومعدات اخرى ابقتهم على
قيد الحياه
كان لدى الفتاه مهاره البقاء على قيد
الحياه الشيء الوحيد الذي اوضحته ليزي
الطفل التي عمرها 13 عاما هو ان والدتها
كانت على قيد الحياه لمده اربعه ايام وهي
التي طلبت منهم مغادره المكان العنايه
الاله وحدها من انقذ الاطفال التائين من
مخالب النمور المتوحشه والافاعي السامه
والحشرات القاتله التي تنتشر في هذه
الغابات المطريه قصه النجاه ستكون مصدر
الهام لمخرججي الافلام وصناع السينما ولكن
قبل ذلك على الحكومه ان تفصل الان في
معركه حضانه الاطفال التي بدات تظهر بين
اقاربهم بعد ان صاروا حديث العالم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات